hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round eight of the
chancre chess tournament also known as
the gush ream of Memorial sorry there's
already a move on the board we have a
game between onigiri and the Magnus
Carlsen Magnus Carlsen is in the lead in
this tournament as of his victory over
Veselin Topalov and giving had a nice
draw against Roth Mahmoud over yesterday
on his birthday so definitely an
interesting clash and if you remember in
the Tata Steel we had a very nice tie
break between unhuman Magnus Carlsen
workhorse and in the end proved that he
is definitely deserving of the title of
world champion
so always an interesting matchup this
game Giri has the white pieces and it's
a really interesting game because
Carlsen plays a very sneaky variation
basically he follows a game played
between Levin our Union and and saw oh
man between Levin Aharon yin and Yan
upon me ah she and Gary also knows that
he is playing that game but he can't
really remember the moves from the game
and each time he makes a move ah he
remembers that that move was actually
played in that game but he doesn't want
to follow that game because he feels
that Carson knows this game and Carson
is like playing moves instantaneously
and Geary has to think and every time he
makes a move he plays the same move as
was played in the game Arnie on the pony
Hoshi but he can't help it because the
move makes sense so it's a very
interesting game and here we even have a
couple of photos here is Geary versus
Carlson I push the board all the way to
the right so you don't see the position
and don't look at the position on the
board you know don't want to spoil it
and we do have one more this is one from
the side I can't make it for screens
it's more of a square photo but here
just so you just so we get the feeling
of the of the space you know and there
we have above them it says in the memory
of vulgar gushy move so I do have
something else prepared but we will get
to that after the game so a giri has the
white pieces and he opens would see
we have E 5 so English opening is on the
board the King's English variation
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 the two
knights variation we have a nice to f3
and the knight to c6 going into the four
Knights variation of the English g3 we
have d5c capture snide captures the
bishop to g2 and night the b6 Giri
castles Bishop to e7 a3 and a5 this is a
come all the moves are from the game 11
are in yon upon me ah she we have D 3
and d 3 was the first move we're gearing
had to think so after this a5 move all
the moves were like played under a
minute some of them even under 10
seconds by Carlsen and d3 is the first
move that gira had to think it took him
eight minutes to decide on d3 across and
castles still playing moves
instantaneously we had Bishop to e3
Bishop to e6 and rook to c1 all the
moves followed that game we have a four
and now comes Knight to d2 what's the
idea why is a wise a four plate well
okay you are you are offering the
character son b6 and after the denied is
the defending the a four square so why
not capture it well if you play Bishop
captures and then seek after some b6
Knight captures on a4 you allow this
very annoying efore move and now you
can't capture because then Queen will
capture Queen and rook captures night
you lose a piece so we'd have to go 91
and then Bishop to g5 attacks the rook
and c1 and you have to move the rookie
to play something like III then the e
captures on d3 is coming and after
Knight captures Bishop to a5 and black
gets insane development for for the
price of that one for the price of that
one a pawn so after this a for a move we
have Knight the d2 by giri not allowing
this efore move to come with tempo on
the night and also not the Knight is
guarding e4 so now capturing is
definitely a possibility and here even
though Carson knows about this game it
took him 12 minutes to decide on his
next move and he does he plays f5 he
again invites give it to capture and
visa
and this time Giri does we have Bishop
captures seek after some v6 and the
knife captures a knife or grabbing a
clean pawn Bishop to g5 now pinning the
night on D to the rope and c1 would be
under attack if denied move and give
immediately retreats Knight to c3 so it
was basically a hit and run we have E 4
by Carlsen now offering Gary a lot of
choices if you if you play something
like D captures then you get Bishop
character sandy to you lost the piece
the knight is undefended so that's
obviously not an option also an idea
could be F for you not you know you
simply say the bishop don't don't attack
my night and D to end after the bishop
moves that will only then capture on e4
the problem is after you play ich after
some f3 emphasis on Knight captures you
get this Bishop to e3 check not even
capturing the rook and c1 but rather
Bishop to e3 checking h1 and now this
Bishop is completely cramping in White's
position and you don't want to even give
up this beautiful Bishop for this rook I
mean you just want to have it there
forever so this would be extremely
unpleasant for white to play so after
this efore move giri couldn't remember
what's the play here he that considered
a couple of things in the game arena and
upon me ah she looked to be one was
played but here get replaced King to h1
this is a novelty and as of this move
it's a completely new game we have Queen
to d7 by Carlsen rook to be one now I'm
pinning the night and now rook a to d8
piling up on that d3 point you could
also grab the point immediately for
example capture capture Queen captures
on b3 wind back the pawn but after
Knight to f3
you want back the pawn the material is
equal but even if you exchange Queens
it's actually white it's better
you just have equal material with a
worse pawn structure
so instead a cross and goes for rook a
to the 8th
there's always time to grab material we
have Knight to c4 by giri and now Queen
to f7 of course if you play something
like Bishop captures then you get the D
captures on c4
not really accomplishing anything so
Queen to f7 Queen to f7 and now you're
definitely threatening Bishop captures
on c4 as if you capture then the Queen
would come under attack from broken d8
b3 now defending the knight with the
b-pawn as well
eek after some d3 characters and III and
the now f4 finally Carlsen gets
something for a spawn he will start an
attack on the White King Geary plays
Knight to e4 attacks the bishop on g5
we'll have Bishop to e7 and now comes G
captures on h4 Carlsen thought that this
wasn't necessarily a mistake by Geary
and he didn't think that Girish position
was bad he just he just thought that it
was ugly and Geary agreed later after
after the game they did some they
analyzed some of the moves with the
legendary duo made Lubavitch and they
both agreed that here is position isn't
bad it's just it's just ugly so G
captures on f4 Queen captures on f4 and
now a four you don't want to capture on
b6 there's really no point to that
you're a three point is under attack so
first giri prevents Carson from
capturing the a3 pawn and now there's
always time to capture on b6 we have
Knights the b4 by Carlson with a double
attack on the d3 pawn and now we have a
vintage gira move this is a move only
giri can come up with
so the d3 point is under attack twice
only the queen is a defending it and
look at the movie refines giri plays
Queen to e2 and Queen to d2 is a monster
move what's the idea behind Queen to d2
well the idea is that after Carson
captures on d3 for example rook captures
on d3 at night the g5 now the bishop on
e6 is attacked twice and also if the
bishop moves the bishop on e7 is under
attack so let's say Bishop captures
now Queen captures on e7 the bishop on
c4 is under attack and the Queen for me
7 is now defending the knight and g5 so
Bishop has to move I would have night
the e6 now attacking the Queen and the
rook so what do you do here
Bishop captures ng to King characters on
g2 and this would now basically force
Carson into forcing
a draw Queen f3 check King g1 and now as
Geary's threatening checkmate here you
don't really have a lot of a lot of
moves you can play here you would simply
have to continue checking the white king
check King moves check King moves and so
on so basically what Gary found after
this night the before move is Queen e2
is basically a draw offer and the water
draw for it is but Carson declines that
he plays Queen to h6 now the queen is
defending the bishop on e6 also he's
making making room for his rook the rook
can now come to a 4 and later to h4 we
have rugby to d1 by giving now the d3
pony's defended and Knight to d5 rock to
g1 and here cross and played King to h8
you could immediately go for something
like Knight to f4 attacking Queen Bishop
but after Queen e3 and there's really no
tactical shot that that accomplishes
anything for black and your knight this
kind of paint here the Queen's are
eyeing each other so after rook to g1
King to h8 my Carlsen I would have
bishop to f1 and rook to f4 finally
bringing the rook into the game rooked
935 by giri and here Carson could go
immediately for rook to h4 the you know
try and do something with this h-file
but after f3 defending the pawn for
example Knights to e3 attacking the rook
and have to rope to d2 Knight to f5
there's again there's there's nothing
serious here for black it's a nice
position and everything but Carson
thinks there's there's even better so
instead of going for this immediately
Carson goes rogue d2 F fate brings
another look into the game so what what
do you do here f3 giri immediately
prepares for for the seizure of the H
file so now the queen is already
guarding h2 rook to h4 by Carlsen and
now d4 so now calls in place and Knight
to f4 and the queen is attacked but also
now the bishop is are attacking the b3
pawn and you can't defend it the b3
point so basically now Carson is winning
back the pawn if you play something
silly like Queen c2 trying to defend it
then Bishop captures mb3 wins the game
you your queen is attacked if you
capture a bishop of course rook captures
on each one finishes the game
immediately that's checkmate and it
doesn't matter even if you play king a
queen bee two or anything
there's no point that point is lost so
give replay tonight study two and we
have a bunch of captures on b3 route B 1
and Bishop captures on a4 so Carlsen
you know gobbled up all of the Queen
side points but it's not really much of
a it's not really a big deal since both
of his Queen side points are doubled on
the B file so Bishop to b5 Gary wants to
exchange this bishop so he can double
rooks on the B file rook Bishop captures
rook captures and now Queen to e6 it's
interesting I checked out this position
during livestream and at the engine
evaluated disposition as as better and
better for black but only only if black
plays Queen e6 and that's exactly what
cousin played so cousin played Queen to
e6 and we have a queen to be to give me
now is preparing to grab the b6 pawn so
Bishop to Bishop to d8 defending the b6
pawn cousin doesn't let him and now
comes the Knight to g5 and again it's a
very tricky variation your queen is
under attack you could choose to grab
the knight immediately but then again
you're beep on it will be under attack
again and crossed plate
Queen to e8 which is again the strongest
move if you play something like Queen 7
this is very tricky white actually
immediately seizes the initiative with
rook to e1 seems like weird move why
would you give up the knight on d5 but
if you do this Queen captures then of
course everyone sees what happens but
you know if by any chance you don't see
immediately feel free to pause it and
try to find the winning move here for
white if this was played then Knight to
f7
would have been deadly now it's check
Queen is under attack you either lose
the Queen and the game or you capture
the night and you get rook to e8 check
Rocka fate and Rock Arizona fate with
checkmate
so after Knight to g5 of course cross
and indigo night
70 went Queenie 8 and we have rook to be
three now and Giri goes back
we have Bishop captures rook captures
and nine three six now cousin attacks
the rook on g5 and also pressures the d4
pawn we had rook to G for a giri forces
and exchange of rooks here
rook captures pawn captures and Queen to
d8 so Queen to d8 is move 40 by Carlsen
so both giri and cost and already made
tank control and now it's move 41 and
here giri was thinking for over half an
hour what to do now he gained more time
they reach time control and now you can
finally relax for the for the last ten
moves giri was in serious time trouble
so it's a of course cousin is a pawn and
his king is a bit safer giri skink is a
bit opened up it's of course a better
position for black but what do you do
here
here get replayed rook to h3 and root 2
H 3 is kind of a blunder it allows
croissant immediately seized the
initiative which he does the only move
that giri could play is actually rook to
f3 rope to f3 with the idea of
exchanging rooks and if Carson plays
Queen to d5 to pin the rook then you
play Queen b3 you defend both the queen
is now defended and the rook is defended
but the problem is here black can
actually play rook captures on f3
temporarily sacrifice the Queen and
after Queen captures rook to f1 check
King to g2 and now Knight to f4 forking
the king and the Queen King captures
Knight captures on d5 and cousin would
still be up upon and I mean it's a BB
pawn but probably winning if any I mean
in cousins hands definitely definitely
definitely winning endgame
so after this Queen to d8 move instead
give replayed rook to h3 but this allows
something give it completely missed here
Carson played Queen to d5 check and this
check allows him to infiltrate a Gary's
position very nicely kink the g1 was
played and now Queen to e4 and this is
probably the move Gary missed now Queen
to you one is a terrible threat you have
to stop this giri played queen to be
for now the queen is guarding b1 and
also a one but there's really a really
no hope of recovery here rook to c8 is
definitely an idea would work to see one
to follow but cousin simply played rook
to f6 and it was in this position that
uh nigiri
resigned the game why did he resign
well I he played rook to f6 so he could
move the knight because he couldn't move
the knight the Queen was eyeing the rock
on f8 now that rook is an f6 there's
really no stopping this night night is
coming to a four and it's game over
we're just gonna show one one variation
for example if Gary tried rope k3 to go
for some rookie ideas then first h5 make
some breathing space for your king and
after the rook goes back for example to
pin pin this point then Knight to f4 but
Knight to a4 is coming in all variations
let's say rook to f3 and now H captures
on g4 rook captures Queen rook captures
there's really nothing you can do here
Queen d2 what's a queen be one check-in
moves Queen f1 check the king is
immediately in the in the mating net
Queen h3 checkmate is a threat if no
Knight moves Queen to f3 checkmate will
be a threat it's a funny position you
can even allow 96 check for King the
king and the rook after the King moves
there's no defense against the Queen h3
or or Queen f3 you capture you get Queen
f3 checkmate now so very nice position
and a very nice game and unfortunately
for Geary he spent too much time trying
to figure out which games were played in
the orange and upon Miasha game and
which weren't and and how to go about
the position so after rook f6 by Carson
Gary resigned the game like I said we
don't have a couple of more things to
show here for example the that Carson
and Geary with the legendary Luba merely
boyish analyzing their position some
position that I don't think this
position occurred on the board but oh
yeah or it did yeah I don't know which
move this was but doesn't really matter
you can see that there and it's very
interesting
Aguirre it's give
is not like other players for example
you will see other players and there
will be very sad after they lose the
game
but it seems like Giri the only games he
loses are actually to Magnus Carlsen so
he doesn't even get upset after losing
to him he's always very cheerful and
always you know gladly analyzes his game
and you know during during the press
conference well it's not a press
conference they just sit down and
analyze the position I know you it's
like you get you get the idea that it's
actually causing who lost you know
that's that's how how strong Giri is
psychologically and of course we have
the standings after round 8 so we have
cause and in first place with five and a
half out of eight three wins 0 losses
and 5 draws and then we have Dingley
Rijn 2 wins 0 losses and six draws so
Carlson and ding so far undefeated in
this tournament tomorrow Carlsen faces
Dean clearance so that's definitely
going to be one of the games that that
will decide the fate of this tournament
and we have a team order a job of zero
who wins zero draws a zero wins 0 losses
and 80 draws then rod oh stop wait a sec
onigiri Veselin Topalov and also sergey
kurakin on 4 out of 8 0 wins 0 losses
and a 2 draws then shock leader Mahmoud
ER of rough Mammadov and David Navarro
in last place with 2 out of 8 so
definitely an interesting tournament and
it's interesting cousin in the well
let's call it press conference said that
you know if you consider his last 10
games that he would rate them mediocre
so I don't know I thought it was kind of
rude to say in front of giri you know
saying you beat the giri with a mediocre
game but yeah okay so yeah that's
basically the game I do hope you enjoyed
it
given definitely didn't but that's
that's just so as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with another game from the from
the United States Championship and
tomorrow we'll definitely catch up on
the cross and England game thank you all